let's make some Korean lettuce wraps
this is called some which literally
translates to rats I chose to grow some
pork belly but feel free to swap it out
with your protein of choice or veggie of
choice cutting the pork belly into
bite-sized pieces instead of moving the
meat to another plate I like to just
push it to the edge of the grill to keep
it nice and warm start your wrap with
the leafy vegetable this is red leaf
lettuce you can also use green leaf
lettuce or Perler leaves by of rice
couple pieces of grilled meat some
kimchi thin slice of garlic and samjang
this one's very very important it's a
fermented soybean sauce that's also
spicy it's so good then you want to wrap
it all up and you gotta eat it in one
bite
babe do you want some Sam
Gotta Have kimchi I'm going with
multiple slices of garlic here and then
some samjang a garnish of rice one bite
it mmm
um
[Music]